ich habe letztens eine 3000 € Saturn wo
dann Tüte mit doppeltem Warenwert
gekauft und das war drin wir haben
gestern etwas kleineres Paket was auch
nicht ganz so schwer ist ich denke aber
da sind halt mehrere Sachen drin habe
ich ja schon gesagt aha Digger nice oh
mein Gott wir haben hier eine Sony
rx100 wie teuer ist die ich weiß es noch
nicht wenn es euch hier ein machen wir
weiter mit mit diesem Gerät was haben
wir denn hier noch eine eine Panasonic
Lumix DMC
tz11 hey und ich glaube das gleiche
haben wir noch ein zweites Mal ich
glaube die wussten dass das Paket an
einen Youtuber raus geht anscheinend
okay was haben wir hier ein Objektiv
oder sehr sehr Hype also das ist ein
fettes das ist ein wirklich fettes
Objektiv